alors on voit à cette montée des eaux
est forcément je me suis posé une
question ce matin j'ai pensé aux rats
est ce que fait météo va-t-elle profiter
il faudra et au sujet des rames même les
si les professionnels sont divisés sur
la question
les rongeurs sont est nettement plus
visible quand leurs terriers sont
inondées regardez vous a fait une petite
compil de tous les rats on peut voir
quand il pleut et je peux vous dire ce
matin en réunion j'ai dit je veux duras
je veux dû ramener en voici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
justement on à lucien cohen ratman
dératiseur qui est avec nous est-ce
qu'il y en a de plus en plus non mais
est-ce qu'il y en a de plus en plus
quand il ya des crues comme ça on les
voit de plus en plus bien sûr qu'il
ressortir au monde c'est logique que les
los montes les égouts ça ça ça remonte
et donc ils sortent et appareils a
passionné au jour là tous l'impression
c'est ce que je dis la semaine dernière
vous êtes vraiment le spécialiste
pourquoi on a tous l'impression qu'il ya
de plus en plus de rats partout en
france
alors je vais vous expliquer tout
simplement c'est parce qu'ils
prolifèrent et prolifèrent il n'y a pas
assez de des gens comme moi entre
guillemets ou d'autres pour attiser
complètement et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup ils ont mis ça dans le dans le
sens où c'est pas trop grave pas
trouvable au jour d'aujourd'hui on
contrôle plus sévère la prolifération
est arrivé à un stade il faut foncer que
un rat ça fait en un coup de grâce a
fait 2 entre deux chaque portée entre
deux et sept petits couacs comme les
d'un incroyable sang la prolifération ça
pouvait plus de 5000 sera bien sûr au
bout d'un an avec dora maison qui voit
là ça fait cent mille donc il faut venir
voir le problème c'est qu'à sa vie avec
2 le souci des rats c'est un faux
problème parce que d'une île n'est pas
plus nuisibles oui ou non on transporte
pas plus de virus que les pigeons amon
que les hommes on voit très bien que nos
chances port du virus une chose le rat
est un animal très intelligent et la
réputation chez nous comme d'autres
animaux ont très mauvaise réputation
par exemple à l'île maurice et les
chiens qui dérange les sciences en lra
nous prendre le problème au départ c'est
à dire que les humains on met trop de
nourriture de partout
elle a raison dans son contexte a nommé
comme ça et c'est pour cela elle a
raison dans le temps au départ ils sont
utiles les rats quoi qu'il arrive alors
pourquoi dans la beauce les ordures etc
stérilement je trouve dans l'est où il
dit
ce nettoyeur exactement et bien sûr le
problème et comme tout cas abandonné
c'est l'excès c'est dire c'est la
prolifération si on contrôle pas la
prolifération
on va être débordé il faut vous dire que
quand même ça apporte plus de 40 maladie
à 1,20 à bâle au rancart être virus et
bactéries xterra lucien que vous avez vu
des choses incroyables
dernièrement oui j'ai déjà vu ben un
truc tout bête c'est à dire qu'avant
vous voyez pas dans un commerce de
bouche j'étais à côté de lyon je vois un
c'est un boulanger qui me raconte pas
des plus simples il va il va pour sortir
justement et des inondations puisse à ce
moment là donc comme arasa il va sortire
d'ailleurs cherché à une conserve une
conserve non il va chercher à d'abricots
pour faire ses devoirs
mais quand il a mis la main le rat il
croyait qu'ils allaient l'attraper ne va
pas vivre à il m'a attrapé la main et ça
fait vraiment un virus qui ne partait
l'hôpital il a eu un enfant n 1 de fiève
extrait effet antibiotique
donc ils sont là aujourd'hui sont là
mais c'est important rien sk moyen
vraiment de s'en débarrasser bien sûr
mais il faut mettre
il faut mettre les moyens aujourd'hui
les 1 coûte très cher téléspectateurs ça
foutrait chien bien sûr ça coûterait
cher pourquoi parce que maintenant il ya
des méthodes attention il faut prendre
vraiment des rates des dératiseurs
professionnels taqwa parce que si c'est
pour vous mettre que quel grain et c'est
parce que des produits aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont dépassés
même leur alors lui même il doit l'être
et ça c'est fini ça non ça existe encore
mais c'est pas ça c'est le poison d'en
mettre des stages c'est pas ça c'est que
l'ena qui font des immunités dans les
portes et de deux les ratons y en a qui
font des immunités dont comme hatier
automatiquement tous les autres vont
être immunisé à ce produit assure le
poison
donc il faut mélanger des poisons mais
j'ai ce que si je crois zara est ce que
c'est c'est quoi ce que j'ai su que sa
mère comme on peut la super c'est que
les gens ont les rails c'est ça qui fait
peur aujourd'hui c'est qu'avant le rat
était craintif maintenant le voiceover
ça se met au jour d'aujourd'hui s'est
habitué à l'homme non mais c'est vrai il
s'est habitué à l'homme
et c'est ça la gravité c'est là que
c'est dangereux parce que laura va
partout au jour d'aujourd'hui
avant il avait peur il faut rester
quatre heures d'adhérents une palette
par exemple les bougeait pas aujourd'hui
c'est le nom qui fait leur force
et aujourd'hui se sont adaptés à l'homme
et ça c'est pas bien c'est pas naturel
donc justement et ils sont dangereux
dans ce sens là et vous savez les urines
les crottes basterra qui lâche qu'on ne
voit pas les urines parce que me
savoureux rappeler l'histoire d'un
canettes les gens travaillent drogue
serait pas ce qu'elle est une légende
je voulais hier aux téléspectateurs il
ya une légende où il faut pas boire dans
la can et directement parce
qu'apparemment les rats à ferait
qu'exacerber les canettes et après les
graves malade c'est pour ça que l'on
sait pas si c'est vrai c'est pour ça
qu'une grosse industrie maintenant les
voiliers seront impactés complètement
des buts et des canettes d'aller corsa
c'est pour éviter justement ce genre de
problème parce que ça leur fait une
mauvaise publicité
mais c'est vrai que dans les entrepôts
et serra les rails bienne hippies et
quand ils pissent ses porteurs de germes
et ça c'est très dangereux
alors il se rend pas compte c'est
dangereux j'ai vu moi un mec très
intelligent on a grand auteur le précité
son nom parce que je veux pas dire
qu'ici qui m'a dit que les rats pourrait
prendre un jour le contrôle
s'il avait cinq fois la taille de
l'homme cinq fois deux rockeuses une âme
et conscience qu'ils étaient supérieurs
à nous en ont pas moi je suis plusieurs
expériences avec des rats j'espère qu'on
les éliminera tous parce que ça a
nettoyé roanne en a besoin a besoin mais
pardon mais on a nos poubelles des
gorges de bouffe c'est qu'il aura est un
animal intelligent et sait où il va et
on doit chercher il a plus peur c'est ça
qui intéresse qu'on a en ce qu'on pense
qu'on doit avoir peur ra maintenant moi
je pense ouattara à la maison je fais
quoi il préfère dératiser moi je vous
dis je vous conseille franchement parce
qu'un rat sait jamais si ça marche pas
mal et un éclaireur qui vient voiture
dehors ça marche familiale femmes et à
gamma c'est pareil vous avez les chefs
le mâle et la femelle les autres même
son art à ces carnivores omnivore il
mange tout c'est à dire même ses
congénères quand il meurt et le beauf
leur machin qui s'adapte à jour et s'est
réveillé la varappe
non mais ça ça peut arriver
ça arrive mais il n'était pas qu'il
était en turquie souvent dans les pays
chauds ça arrive que les clochards les
pauvres malheureusement qui danse dans
la rue
maintenant que c'est fait bouffer le
plus de bénéfices grâce ça arrive et il
fut une époque ça arrive et leur à ces
carnivores c'est omnivore ça mange tout
ça s'adapte à toutes les situations
c'est à dire c'est simple qu'on peut
revenir à ce que disait madame isabelle
maury ne sait quand
quand vous êtes en laboratoire vous
voyez que les rares on n'est pas
pourquoi parce que ils font tous les
tests ils y arrivent à résoudre tous les
problèmes humains c'est ça donc si vous
voyez ils ont une forme d'intelligence
ex supérieur c'est à dire quelque part
que pour ce petit animal qu'est ce
qu'ils font c'est à dire tous les
problèmes vous allez voir même si par
exemple là il trouve une solution pour
aller de sur l'autre berge
il faut qu'il montre sur un morceau bois
vous mme rice et d'essayer de ma de vous
améliorer à chaque fois pareil forcément
et il faut être malin avec les rapaces
que les races et intelligents ils savent
comment se déplacer par exemple vous
mettez un poison il va pas venir manger
instinctivement il va sans dire que
c'est un danger pour lui la noire et
sinon ils étape est avec le fromage
ça va marcher c'est vrai j'ai fait le
problème c'est la prolifération toujours
si vous attrapez un pour attraper en a
dix qui vont parvenir à taper sa faveur
lui les mots
faire deux minutes après base
d'anticoagulants oui bah oui parce que
ça ne fait pas tout de suite pour éviter
justement que les autres
j'enrage or ils sont pleins dry combat
dit j'aurais valley frère basile toit
très bien je trouve c'est très bien fait
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça sans
nous voir quand les alpha il enlève
qu'ils envoient les liviu les malades et
ramallah et à gaza ils vont tester mais
ça peut ça les a passées le ceux qui
commentent il ya un vieux mâle et la
femelle et ben euh il en va bientôt au
casse pipe
les autres en moyenne c'est combien
c'est à dire at il un appartement il
faut compter 2 combien il faut compter
entre eux on va dire 300 euros et ça
peut monter ses dépens l'infestation
parce que le problème ne s'est pas
devenir une intervention c'est de
continuer parce que si vraiment vous
avez des trous il ya plein de choses qui
rentrent en considération et pas
seulement de l'un des poisons il faut
voir comment c'est fait c'est dans les
faux plafonds cdr des murs parce qu'ils
sont partout aussi ainsi on a déjà la
première quand vous regardez sirène
ronger c'est bien qu'ils iront beaucoup
les câbles électriques et parce qu'ils
ont tous constante c'est ça le problème
jeunes pousses constante et son jus
d'orange et moi je ne ronge timer
ah oui si on jeta humeur et en plus de
ça c'est pour quand vous dire excusez
moi j'ai perdu un peu le fil de sa force
vous avez des crottes
comme je vous ai dit si vous l'avez
décrit les conneries grains de café et
il sourit c'est un tout qui tient un
tout petit peu plus petits accor compte
quand vous voyez ça en général c'est que
dans les baguettes de pain dans la mie
de pain il ya des crottes non cuite dans
la baguette
ça arrive et allait bien le problème
c'est wallace et c'est une histoire
aussi d'hygiène c'est important et
affichant excusez moi malheureusement il
ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui sont sous
le seuil de pauvreté et qui l'est c'est
bien d'aller chez eux mêmes et c'est pas
que chez les pauvres a aussi nuancé
c'est tout le monde il ya des rats dans
les yachts ça peut s'arrêter bien sûr ça
arrive tard où ils passeront mieux dans
tous les continents parler par des
bateaux absolument
est ce qu'on peut craindre un scénario
catastrophe vu la prolifération la
montée des eaux de millions de rats
défilant dans les rues d un jour alors
moi je veux pas faire peur mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'on commence à être
un peu débordés ne croyez pas cessé la
prolifération et là c'est à dire que
juste qu'on a entendu un truc que dans
la fois sur les rats il paraît que les
chats ils ont peur des races que ces
groupes à 3 du tout pas du tout donc les
charges toujours le rachaï peur mais en
général à chaque et kiki qui a un qui
est un vrai prédateur il a aucune raison
d'avoir de mes deux chats comme ça dans
mon appart avec des brassards sécurité
intérieure a trop vite c'est vrai
vraiment d'accord très bien oui allez
les questions c'est gilles parlé tout
fait lors d'invasions doha il a raison
de s'inquiéter il ya des villes où il ya
plus de rack d'habitants je crois qu'à
paris un train mais moi j'ai plus de
râteau collective
ras à paris intra muros est ce que l'on
avait pensé à l'union je suis à paris à
lyon à lyon il ya un million quatre
draps on va dire maintenant ils arrivent
à deux millions c'est facile parce que
ça prolifère tellement bien il faut vous
dire aussi c'est le confinement sap a
fait du bien le confirmation le
compliment tout ça c'est que les
poubelles et les rails sortent plus
facilement
bien sûr par exemple chez je me rends
compte que à paris c'est un vrai
problème
on s'est mis à lyon bon j'ai une boîte à
lyon que tu connais qui s'appelle fans
histoire de faire un petit peu de pub
porte de montrer d'une façade s'appelle
sat e h f
vous avez tous les produits s'est même
pas chez moi c'est tous les produits
pour acheter la dératisation les rats
sont attirés et quelle est leur
espérance de vie en moyenne très bonne
question de m sow alors là on est une
petite question personne n'a posé ici et
d'être tout simplement ils sont attirés
par la nourriture c'est la vérité c'est
à dire que les poubelles et tout ce que
vous traînez ils vont partout dès qu'ils
sentent la bouche comme et jean un rat
ça veut dire il est comme chacun peut le
maire les aquarelles copule il bouffe
ouais mais il faut que qui fait voilà et
puis il faut savoir qu'un razavi pas
longtemps sa vie maximum 24 mois non
vraiment quatre mois quatre mois c'est
pas c'est pas énorme mais la
prolifération même problème c'est la
prolifération et quand ça vous fait
entre deux et sept petits malfrats qui
ont fait entre nous et cette petite 16
rapports très vite ou alors tu composes
en amidon de maïs un truc comme ça les
rats et raffole de ça devrait aller voir
le jour
on fait ce qu'il est plus chaud qu'avant
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya cette
prolifération qu'est ce qui fait qu'il
fait plus ça que avait déjà il dilapide
prédateur mais déjà il y en eut pas
ensuite les gens font moins attention on
a par exemple la mairie par xterra ils
ont des budgets mais je pense à côté la
mano ils n'ont pas lieu d'être
ils ont pas mis les paquets qui le
paquet qu'il faudrait et dans toutes les
villes et moussa koussa ça c'est un coup
il faut pas il faut pas vous cacher le
rap ça coûte des millions d'euros de
dégâts
non les raves coûter entre les rats et
des souris entre aussi bien les
entreprises que les sociétés ou les
particuliers les rats font tellement de
dégâts que ça coûte des millions d'euros
c'est la folie à l'élection sur les rats
là sans rigoler ça
du coup je les entends de questions
c'est un truc de fou êtes comme moi vous
êtes à fonctionner ce que c'est vrai que
les rats non seulement sont de plus en
plus intelligents mais aussi de plus en
plus agile il remonte dans les étages
élevés par les toilettes et on m'a dit
par les gouttières oui alors on se rend
compte de plus en plus et que leur art
en général rester toujours dans les sous
sols
au jour d'aujourd'hui on se rend compte
qu'ils montrent dans les étages et oui
quoi je renvoie l'ascenseur l'oreille
c'est à dire immonde et qui commet il
commence à monter que soient laissées
dans l'ascenseur troisième du moins
dangereux au quatrième je vois chaque
chakra cherche aussi à faire sa famille
cherche à faire son territoire n'a donc
attention un autre à qui rend dans un
territoire où c'est comme tous les
animaux il va se défendre il va s'il va
se battre contre les autres donc ce qui
est important ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
rue du moins c'est que les rats monte
prévenir que maintenant on dirait qu'ils
ont plus de place en bas j'ai entendu
dire son negra peuvent sauter vrai ou
faux oui jusqu'à un mètre cinquante et
sénateurs était très bas selon leur âge
les kamas il en débardeur un numéro 8
ces cinq mètres wesh qu'un médecin quand
c'est ça le danger qu'on peut avoir
c'est justement vous retrouver face à un
rat il se sent coincé parce que l'europe
va pas vous attaquez normalement quand
on commence à voir des choses bizarres
6e sans danger il pense que vous allez
lui faire du mal ou que vous avez
l'agresser il va s'il va se défend
chaque balle et j'ai rechargé
il va aux feux de l'amour d'un mètre
cinquante et qui sera embêtant c'est de
faire mordre par exemple il peut comme
ça il pas là bah oui parce qu'il veut se
défendre c'est pas parce qu'il a peur il
a plus peur qu'autre chose ah ouais
alors juste sur les rats vous avez vous
raconter un truc qui vous est arrivé
dans l'instant et qu'il y aura plus de
poubelles laura finira par attaquer
l'homme
non ça c'est une question de bon goût
non mais on va était le rasad absire que
la prolifération c'est qu'il ya plus en
plus de bouffe ça veut dire que moi ya
pas moins de bouffe mais voilà eh ben ça
va régresser ça va régresser mis à part
bien sûr qu'il faut traiter peut-être
est passé un mois j'ai eu du mal à nous
mais ils vont chercher comment c'est
pour ça qu'ils prolifèrent et plus on
trouve donc plus ils peuvent proliférer
et puis il ya moins de déprédateurs donc
tout ça dans des questions à la question
je sais capable à plein de questions
c'est la police a vraiment je serai
attendu ligne alors c'est pour ça que
j'ai contacté l'association aux polices
paris oui il propose de faire des
sachets poubelles plus épais et
hermétique du coup la manie vont plus et
ce prolifèrent - pas mal
très bonne idée mais ce à un coût
malheureusement les gens ne veut pas
payer mais si vous faites venir tu vas
pas me laisser la mairie c'est pas la
mairie c'est tout le monde quoi il écrit
voilà c'est les jeunes et les gens
l'agent général ne veulent pas mais
c'est déjà le sac poubelle on se rendait
sur l'île le temps qu'on le mettant en
place de mettre des ordures dans un sac
poubelle il a fallu du temps mais ça il
faut le mettre en place et seulement
apprendre aux gens c'est un cola
pernikoff gavin question alors lui s'est
alors glissé race rahmane
je suis je suis démission j'adorais os
des abats merci et j'adore série donc la
merci mon lucien mais je suis pas
politicien récemment jeu il ya des parcs
avec des enfants il ya des rats parler
n'ont pas rejeté
il n'y a pas longtemps unis gt gt dans
un bar bada d'immeubles et y aller les
poubelles qui met à l'extérieur comme ça
et je vous assure je raconte pas
d'histoires j'ai voulu filmer j'ai pas
filmer il y avait peut-être dans un type
mais un une sorte de jardin mais ferme
et 6 mais pas 500 rats qui sortait en
pleine journée
alors moi comme il s'en fait un côté et
tes jambes et naturellement gym année un
truc qui m'a pardon alors est-ce que
c'est dangereux pour les enfants dans
les parcs ou chasser alors moi je dis
que c'est dangereux dans quel sens dans
le sens suivait un bonbon il est assis
d'un moment le rail vient et pour le
petit prendre mon gâteau le rail crois
que c'est pour lui au pyla il attrape on
sait jamais attention le risque qu'il
est n'est pas autant que ça mais il faut
faire attention quand même c'est ce que
vous avez déjà avant qu'on vous voulez
ce un bien sûr qu'on est en hiver parce
que c'est vrai que ça intéresse pas
c'est la folie sur les rails a
actuellement juste lucien est ce que
vous avez vous une aventure que vous
voulez raconter à nos téléspectateurs
voilà sur l'ir a dernièrement ce qu'il
voit là il ya eu un truc incroyable
moi moi là je l'avais est échue je suis
un peu craintifs possédera pas encore
parce que je suis dératiseur moi ce que
j'ai peur de me faire porter sur tout ça
une fois j'étais chez un dans un dépôt
comme ça je le ferai que les techniciens
accord avec chypre
voilà vous avez appelé parce qu'ils
avaient des repas il avait des rats donc
on rentre on fait on voir un verre les
caves ex terra et d'un coût d'un coup je
vois et choix que ça ça passe mais pas
question je vois pas mais je vois ta ta
ta parce que c'était son sein je sais
pas je vois exactement tbh russie d'un
coup je vois une dizaine de rats qui
reviennent de l'autre côté il charge
comme ça en charge ils sont sur
l'égalisation il charge
on dirait qu'ils vont charger sur moi
ils ont 17 ans je suis voilà mon avis
bord on connaît mieux reçu leur matériel
défoncée non j'y accole un gâchis des
prix on veut le faire des attentats sion
bouille a dit rice ils sont bons ça dit
il à la tactique par les icônes environ
oui comment on va rire le montant à
lever entre 1,25 et non vous avez filmé
ouais j'ai flippé la belge a vu des
appartements mwasesa que voudrait sait
pas l'utiliser mais aussi des
appartements infestés de rats qui font
affaire il faut quitter l'appartement
c'est pas qu'il faut quitter
l'appartement il faut traiter parce que
si mes mais tellement assad mais c'est
c'est un peu dégueulasse que je le dis
en vérité c'est si je pense que ses
propriétaires honnêtement henry et ils
savent qu'ils ont des gens qui vivent au
mois qu'ils ont des menus très modeste
experts à illies les met dans des
appartements c'est comme on dit là vous
savez au moins même assuré marchands de
sommeil est donc nettement sinon c'est
une honte
moi je capte il s'est même pas ça c'est
qu'il veut même pas payé c'est dans la
mer cet anime normal mais y'a un
restaurant à la base et moi j'ai
régulièrement des petits rats qui rentre
dans l'appartement comme la cb sullivan
a toujours manqué d'en changer
je vais pas faire genre le médiateur le
gall le garçon gentil mais il ya pas si
longtemps que ça à lyon à lyon j'étais
dans un foyer
il y avait un peu il y avait un problème
de rats et le gros pétards ne veut rien
savoir
il y avait tellement vraiment problème
les gens ne comprennent vraiment mal au
coeur parce qu'il y avait une dame avait
deux enfants la pauvre vous n'avez été
que j'ai traité gratuitement je n'ai pas
pensé exceptionnel c'est vraiment un
cutter et je sais moi la paix demande
est traitée si vous avez deux enfants
dont un bébé c'était c'était horrible
quoi je veux dire les rails après par
les enseignants